i want to start with congratulations on
foundation i've seen the first eight
episodes
what do i need to give you to get
episodes nine and ten in my account
ask apple you know we are um i believe
delivering episode nine to apple today
literally
uh and episode 10 i think we're turning
in next week we still got about 22
visual effects shots that we're
finishing um
but uh i i
i think they deliver i think i think we
stuck the landing
right well you if i'm not mistaken uh
directed the finale of season one
yes
and so was it you cherry-picking that
episode because of how much happens in
it or how did you end up directing that
episode
there were two reasons um
you know i don't think either of them
were selfish uh
one of them was just practical which is
as the show runner i was there during
all of production
um
because i directed episode 10 there
wasn't anyone coming after me that i had
to help prep the episode with so i was
on set
for 90 of the filming and because often
times we shot out of order uh six
different countries you know i would be
there to remind the directors the cast
okay
this is what's going on this is what
happened immediately before this moment
this is what's emotionally important
about this moment this is where we're
building towards
but um there wasn't anyone to prep after
me so i i
the burden of show runner was off my
shoulders at that point i think the
other reason why i did it was because
again for a related reason we had to
stick the landing on all of these story
points you'll see when you see epic
episode uh 10 it's
it's a culmination both filmically and
emotionally for kind of all of these
breadcrumbs that we've been spreading
throughout the season
and um
i just
i i just needed to be certain that i
could get the actors there also some of
the actors didn't
read the tenth script until we shot it
so i'd kept some of the information um
from them i didn't want uh their
characters and the actors to know what
was going to happen so i needed to be
there to kind of you know hand hold them
through all those moments because there
quite a few surprises happen in the
final episode
when i saw you at this apple event it's
a while ago now up in northern
california yes
david ellison and everything and i
remember asking you something to the
effect of i mean this is a really big
show is apple going to spend the money
to really do this and i remember that i
remember that and you were you said
something like yeah and now that i've
seen the show the answer is yeah they
did um this is what we call a big
budgeted show there's there's a lot to
this can you sort of talk about that for
fans that might be nervous that this
isn't going to be done right
i mean it
the budget was ample although it wasn't
as big as some other shows that are out
there i think the key for us though is
we had a tremendous amount of time to
prep it to plan it ahead of time
so um
if you really know what you're building
towards and you really know what you're
designing towards then you can really
stretch the dollar what was important
for me is that
um you know
we had what what i said were you know
these are moments these are scenes that
we're gonna film like david lean
and these are other moments that we're
gonna film like very elevated television
but it was just really important to me
that everything feel unified that it
feels cinematic that's why we filmed in
six different countries um all of the
directors of photography and all of the
directors we would have these
um
sessions where we would sit and we would
watch films that would inspire us or we
would talk about what is terminus going
to look like across these different
episodes and make sure that it was lit
the same way and that the color
temperature was the same it was really
important to me
that the
the show have a unique and unified
feel and look and that the show felt
lived in and that it felt like it wasn't
shot against a green screen
yeah um success uh did you really and i
could be wrong about this but did you
really pitch apple on an eight-season
80-episode arc
i did
and so
uh right i'm all i love having that
information and knowing that um that you
look they they they knew that it was
this was an enormous undertaking and a
big proposition and
and and an enormous investment not just
in terms of money but in terms of time
in terms of
all the hundreds and hundreds of people
at apple that are working on this and um
i think it was important to them and it
was fair
that that
they
knew that i wasn't just riffing you know
that there was some kind of end point we
were writing to so
um you know we spent about two hours and
i told them my grand plan
in success if we get there uh it doesn't
mean we can't shimmy along the way and
we can't make adjustments but um i do
have an endpoint in mind at least for
now i do know where all the major
characters land and what happens at the
end of it hopefully we'll get there
uh i have to ask you as obviously a fan
of the series now uh where are you in
the writing process for season two if
apple picks it up is it something where
you could be in production next year
yes
[Laughter]
so where can i so can you be more
specific where are you in the writing
process or do you know what i mean
um
they would not have allowed me to
proceed with season one if i didn't have
the bulk of season two already figured
out
i understand one i'll i'll leave it
there um one of the things that i really
appreciate about the show is that it is
not dumbing itself down for the audience
it takes place over there's many time
jumps there's many planets and there's
no honestly there's no stupid exposition
dumps where people are just ex like it
made me very happy uh can you sort of
talk about the fact that this is
intelligent this is a really complicated
and intelligent story
it's an ambitious story
in every way shape and form and i i but
i also have to credit the audience and
some of the streaming shows that have
come before us um with sort of i think
the medium is caught up to asimov i
think
people enjoy the experience of settling
in for a story that's going to unfold
over 10 episodes or you know multiple
seasons watching characters grow i think
as long as the audience
feels like you're writing towards
something um they're okay with not every
question being answered i will say
most of the questions that the audience
has over the course of season one will
be answered by episode 10 but not all of
them and if there's a question that we
haven't answered there's a reason why we
haven't answered it and um
it's not because we forgot about it it's
it's watch this space
there um hopefully it's something that
the audience
will be able to enjoy upon first viewing
but we'll also be able to enjoy upon
second viewings there are a lot of
easter eggs in there um
a close-up isn't just a close-up uh um
that's part of the fun
uh i'm because of all the time jumps and
the way you're telling the story how did
anything possibly change in the editing
room that you weren't expecting
did you end up taking something from say
episode five and move it to three
because you're like oh that would work
better there
believe it or not no
i didn't
there were some things that changed in
the editing but i would say
primarily the only things that changed
in the editing were sometimes the order
of the storylines within the episode we
moved scenes around
and i would say that the voice over
gail's voiceover
i might have rewritten about 20
uh in post-production but believe it or
not
we didn't move anything from one episode
to another episode it was really
that well planned out
what's interesting about this year
specifically the end of this year are
three major properties that have been
talked about for forever i'm
specifically talking about foundation
dune and sandman which you're also
involved in are all finally going to be
coming out this is stuff that people
have you know talked about for so long
um can you sort of talk about the fact
that we're entering this amazing age
where these
massive stories can be
told
again even though even though dune is
coming out as a feature i really credit
the streaming audience for this uh for
um it was unimaginable to me i was
offered foundation
10 15 years ago to adapt as a feature
and then i thought it was impossible to
adapt as a feature even a series of
features
uh we attempted the same thing was
attempted with sandman um and it's very
strange to me that
after literally decades of of me
dreaming about working on foundation or
sandman that both would come my way at
almost exactly the same time after
decades of
various attempts um
failing um it's it's it's funny how that
worked out but i do think in the case of
sandman
and foundation um
a streaming show was was the perfect and
really the only way that the magic of
what asimov and gaiman
had done could be fully realized
and
look i'm a fan of dune and i'm i'm very
much looking forward to that film as
well
yeah you know i've seen dune and what's
interesting is it totally um i don't
want to go off on a tangent but it it's
completely different than foundation in
the way
[ __ ] it but we'll skip that um i do have
a f i have a follow up because i could
just talk about it with you and geek out
but that's not what the audience wants
to hear about uh i want to ask you one
question about sandman if you don't mind
because you never really know how it's
going to be
until you get in the editing room
obviously that's the final rewrite what
did you discover in the editing room
with sandman that maybe you weren't
expecting what can you tease fans
[Music]
there's very little i can say that's not
a spoiler i mean
i mean truthfully
um i will say this uh i think it's a
very truthful adaptation
and uh some of the individual issues
that we adapted
um that were perhaps
the trickiest uh standalone issues in
gaiman's run have ended up being the
most interesting and
kind of genre-bending episodes and i'm
really proud of those
not wait one of the things getting back
to foundation one of the things that i
think that you did a great job with was
taking a lot of characters that were
men in the book switching them to women
and also at making sure this is a you
know a diverse cast can you sort of talk
about those two aspects
i mean frankly frankly those two aspects
um
were the two things that i lit upon
first and and the two questions that i
posed the asthma of a state
uh
in the first novel there are virtually
no female characters whatsoever and i
said it's just inconceivable to me to
think about adapting this now 70 years
later and not
gender flipping some of these characters
and it's also inconceivable to me
especially with the global reach of
something like apple tv plus
that the characters in the show wouldn't
reflect the audience of today
uh fortunately that's something that uh
robin asimov and the asimov state
completely embraced and they said
you know isaac asimov himself would have
embraced that and and so once i heard
that i felt fairly comfortable about it
that was a no-brainer for me
um i think it also um first of all i i
i'm very happy you did it and also it
just adds so much to the story you know
by by doing this it just opens up other
things
yeah yeah i mean it of course
the show has to reflect the audience i
mean we're also we're extrapolating
about a society that's going to exist on
10 000 worlds in the future and so how
would it not be
you know multi-sexual and multicultural
height i mean it would have to be
completely this uh your shoot i think
was like basically 17 years between cove
between the start and the end yeah i
think i was 12 when we started yeah
exactly i am a lot of times when i speak
to um to to filmmakers and and creative
people they talk about a break in
between filming can actually be a
benefit because you are looking at all
the footage you see what you have what
you're missing and so could you sort of
talk about did that break actually help
make season one better
it absolutely helped make season one
better we had shot about three episodes
we had about a five month break and i uh
had the advantage of going into the
editing room and starting to cut those
episodes together
seeing what was working seeing what
wasn't working um
changing the voice over but also looking
at our various cast members and
i had the ability to sort of play to
their strengths and realize oh my god
that scene i'm i'm gonna tweak
uh the script a little more to lean into
that and that's
that's something that um
you know under normal circumstances you
would never have the ability to do
there's no question the show benefited
from it
uh
i'm curious talk a little bit if you
don't mind working with apple and
what kind of notes do they give as
compared to the other people you've
worked with uh can you sort of talk
about that dan because they're a
relatively new studio
i have to say my experience with apple
was
was excellent it really was i mean i
pitched a very
very bold
vision for the show i don't think a show
like this has ever been made before
um
and and and really the only overriding
note that they gave me was
rooted in emotion
rooted in emotion as as long as we
understand where the characters are
coming from and where they're moving
towards um just rooted in motion i'll
give you a perfect example
uh in in the first uh foundation story
we pick up gail dornick on an elevator
you know or on a ship just arriving at
trantor
and a note that both sky dance and apple
gave me and josh freeman who i covered
the first episode with was
can we have a scene with gail on her
home planet before she gets to trantor
well that's not a scene that existed
in
asimov's book
but then once you think about that
and you understand that gail's a point
of view character i mean it's just such
a tremendous opportunity to see where
this character came from
to understand then what they're building
towards and where they're going towards
and and so i i would get notes like that
and they were almost always rooted in
what is this character thinking
what do they
what do they hope for what are they
afraid of
and i would say that the thing that the
rule that i applied not just for the
writers but for the directors and the
actors is
i i took that note and then i would say
okay every scene every storyline
let's strip away the science fiction
let's strip away the spaceships and the
robots and the nanotechnology
and the bishop's claws which your
hopefully viewers will know what those
are
and we'll say does this story work
if it were just a contemporary drama
can you know what's a version of the
story that existed if this were
happening
on any contemporary show
and as long as i could
understand that story and pitch it back
to apple
then i felt like we were in a good space
and hopefully we've been able to do that
with the show
100
i'm about to run out of time with you
i'm very close to the end i do want to
ask you about hellraiser because i need
to ask you about hellraiser if you don't
mind um
big question is is doug bradley have any
sort of role in it
i can't say i will say that we went back
to the original novella for the source
material we're really being we're really
honoring clive's work i can say that
david bruckner is a genius
it's filming right now the footage is
terrifying and amazing and the cenobytes
are jaw-dropping
i i'm also curious um is it would you
categorize it as violent super violent
or oh my god violent
[Laughter]
i'm not going to answer that question
right so so it's definitely a rated r
though yes
got um yeah i'm very very when do you
think fans will get like a first look
you know like stuff like that
i genuinely don't know we're we're
literally in the midst of filming it
right now
um so my last question for you um what
actually i don't know how involved you
are with sandman like on a day to day
and how it all works but what exactly
happens
to you
if sandman is a big hit this is a big
hit and both are sort of going next year
what exactly is your life
very complicated it was already very
complicated um
never in my wildest dreams did i imagine
i would work on
either of these shows much less both of
these shows at the same time uh it's
it's it's been a privilege and um and
it's a bit crazy and i'm i'm just glad
that my wife supports both of the shows
um
so basically you're effed next year both
get a season two
i i'll need to clone myself like the
cleons
oh hey listen um because i'm out of time
um i would love to actually talk to you
about specific spoilers after i get to
see the finale and run it down the road
because i didn't i would love to i know
i'm i'm dying to talk about the show
after people see episode 10. yeah i i
because i didn't ask anything
specifically especially about that the
the religious there's so many things i
want to get into but i can't say it you
know what i mean let's let's do it
apple happy to do it